I have been shot at multiple times in my life for being,
for trespassing.
Yes.
Okay.
That's crazy.
We need to talk about that off air.
Holy cow.
What?
Okay.
That's,
that's some,
that's some Virginia stuff right there.
That's some Virginia stuff right there for sure.
Yo,
yo.
Alrighty,
man.
You ready?
Here we go.
Crack the neck.
Gonna do the stand back,
the little,
little shimmy before we get into the podcast episode.
Get the blood flowing.
Yep.
Well,
I don't know,
man.
I feel like I'm more tired than you and it's only 5 PM where I am.
I don't know.
Well,
yeah.
So I,
I've been actually using this really interesting app.
It's called time shifter.
And it's supposed to help with jet lag adjustment.
And so basically you tell it like what flights you're going to be taking and what your sleep
schedule normally is.
And then it will tell you like a couple of days before,
like,
Oh,
go to bed,
like two hours later,
don't see sunlight,
don't drink coffee.
And then like,
when you get there,
like you should have told me this,
I,
for the record,
for,
to clear up this conversation,
uh,
Joel is currently in Tokyo,
for the hacker one live hacking event.
I will be leaving in about 12 hours.
To go to Tokyo.
So dude,
so this app,
like it tells you how to beat jet lag.
Is that the vibe?
Yeah.
I mean,
that's the goal.
Um,
they actually have like a partnership with United.
So if you have a 1k membership,
you get like a free year of it or something.
Um,
but,
uh,
even still,
it's like 25 bucks a year.
It's like really not that bad.
Um,
and yeah,
it's been pretty interesting.
It's,
you know,
if you've traveled a lot,
it's not anything you're probably not,
you know,
already aware of in terms of like,
try to go to bed at a normal time.
Like just trying to like stay up and take melatonin before you go to bed.
And,
um,
the light I think is a really big,
important thing because when you,
when you take light into your retinas,
it,
uh,
it helps your circadian rhythm adjust.
You're supposed to have light in the morning and in the evening.
Yeah.
And that's one of the things that they recommend.
And then I noticed that helped quite a bit of just like getting light into my eyes and,
uh,
helping sort of just reset my sleep.
When you talk about light in the morning,
it makes me think of that little,
that little meme of the eagle,
you know,
like going on the stupid mental,
stupid little walk from my stupid mental and physical,
you know what I'm talking about?
Like,
very relatable.
Yeah.
Okay.
I have to see light.
Yeah.
We need to,
we need to,
I guess we need to get somebody to overlay that on the screen.
We should note that down.
Little,
little eagle meme.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice man.
Well,
well,
uh,
how's the,
how's the live hacking event going for you?
We're not,
we're not team critical thinking this time,
so I haven't caught up with you at all.
How's it going?
Yeah.
It's been pretty good.
Um,
it's been a pretty hard target.
I'm not going to lie.
Um,
I found a couple of things,
did some collaborations,
uh,
with Shubs.
So yeah,
we found,
um,
you know,
we found one,
one really interesting thing together,
but it's been a pretty tough target.
I'm not going to lie.
Um,
I think a lot of people,
I don't know.
Are we allowed to say who it is?
I know it's kind of public.
I think we are allowed to say the,
yes,
we are allowed to say the,
the primary target.
Okay.
Yeah.
So it's PayPal.
Um,
so yeah,
I,
I know a lot of people,
there's a special scope.
I'm not going to say what it is.
Um,
but there's a special scope and then there's the PayPal scope.
And I know a decent amount of people have actually been focusing on the PayPal scope.
Um,
I know I was speaking with Nagly and Nagly had some really interesting stuff on the main scope for PayPal.
so yeah,
it's been,
it's been a really interesting event.
I'm excited to see what people are finding.
I haven't even checked the leaderboard.
So I,
I wonder how many bugs are in and stuff,
but,
uh,
I think it's going to be a cool event.
Yeah,
I think it's,
it's been a little bit of a tricky one for me too.
I've,
I've got a,
I think I've got a good number of reports that I'm comfortable with and happy with,
but it's just dupe palooza because the,
the special scope that they added for this one is like just very,
very narrow and not extremely featureful.
So,
uh,
you know,
you really have to dig deep and you got to find everything.
And,
uh,
yeah,
it's just,
I think I,
out of my 23 reports,
I think like 18 or 19 are duplicates,
including all of my bugs above a,
uh,
high and above.
So I have no,
maybe I might have one.
I might have one solo high.
We'll see.
Okay.
But,
uh,
my,
the crit that I have or the two crits that I have are all dupes.
And so it's just like stabbed to the heart.
Damn.
Well,
if it's a crit,
we'll,
we'll have to see.
I was speaking with Naglin apparently because of the way that this whole account setup works.
And I think,
you know what I'm talking about?
Um,
they might be doing privileges required low at minimum for everything.
Yeah.
So that's kind of,
kind of annoying,
kind of frustrating.
I don't think personally,
it's kind of personally,
I don't think that it,
that,
yeah,
I know they had some like special stuff in the backend.
I think when we were signing up to make it,
so we didn't get flagged as spam.
So maybe that's why,
you know,
you actually do need a little bit of privileges required.
It's not as simple as just like signing up for your own account.
Um,
yeah,
maybe we'll see.
We'll see at the event,
man,
you know,
not trying to,
toot my own horn or anything here,
but your boy has some persuasive skills.
And then,
you know,
put,
put me,
put me in front of the team.
If you could swing it for the whole team.
Yeah.
That would be clutch.
That'd be clutch.
Cool.
All right.
So we got a bunch of questions,
I think that,
uh,
we're going to go over.
Yeah.
Let's,
let's take a peep,
um,
at these,
uh,
we're trying to keep this episode pretty chill today since Joel and I are both in the middle,
in the throes of a live hacking event.
So we went back and looked at,
uh,
Twitter posts from a while back when we were giving away the Kaido pro subscription,
um,
and kind of grab some questions off there for us to kind of discuss.
Um,
let's do,
let's go ahead and start with our boy Jew Bob's,
uh,
and let's talk about,
awesome.
Does bug bounty hunting unconditionally qualify as ethical hacking?
Do you think?
So I think,
I think you Bob's coming in with the hard hitting questions,
man,
like some serious questions.
So the thing is when you call it bug bounty hunting,
I think that kind of implies,
at least the way that I understand it,
that kind of implies that you're hacking on a bug bounty program.
And to me,
when I think about it that way,
that implies also that you are complying with a program policy.
And so theoretically,
most of the time it's ethical hacking,
but I think we both know that safe Harbor isn't foolproof.
And there are certainly edge cases and well,
not even educate.
There are cases where you will be going out of safe Harbor.
If you,
you know,
do,
do certain things,
right?
So if you're do bug bounty hunting and you extort the team,
that's not ethical hacking,
right?
Like asking for,
you know,
do this or I'm going to release the data or I'm going to keep it.
Like anything like that,
I don't consider that ethical.
So I think there are,
there are certainly lines that you can cross to make it non-ethical,
but from like a baseline standpoint,
just reporting a bug to,
to a bug bounty program,
that's absolutely ethical in my opinion.
So I have a little bit of a differing opinion on this and it's going to be
interesting because it also kind of toes the boundary of what I was talking
about last week,
which was it's,
it's not our responsibility to define a company's threat model for them,
but I would feel a little bit yucky about reporting something that is,
that the company wanted to receive that I know full and well is technically
impossible to exploit.
So I've got a good example of this.
Okay.
So let's say I got a bunch of,
I don't know why lately,
but I get a bunch of DMS and lately a lot of people have been asking about
access control origin star header,
right?
Uh,
you know,
access with,
uh,
you know,
asterisk origin plus the,
allow any credentials.
Exactly.
Plus the access control,
allow credentials,
true header.
Those two,
those two things together.
Theoretically,
what this,
what should happen with this is that you're allowed to send cookies and then
any origin is allowed to read the response.
Right.
But goals,
goals defined.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the people that defined the spec thought,
Hey,
this is dumb.
We shouldn't allow them this to happen.
Um,
and,
uh,
and they said,
Hey,
this is,
this is not going to be exploited.
We're not,
we're not going to make this,
you can't use the access control credentials,
true with the asterisk origin.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you know,
people are messaging me like,
Hey,
how do I exploit this?
And I'm telling them,
Hey,
this is not exploitable,
even though it's clearly a misconfiguration.
Like those headers cannot be working together.
You know,
well,
they,
they just don't work together.
It causes an error.
Yeah.
So,
um,
you know,
if you were to report that,
right.
And the team were to accept it and you know that the team accepts that,
let's say you,
you reported it when you didn't know whether it was a bug or not.
And the team accepted it and paid it out.
Then you found another one,
but you,
now,
you know that it is not,
it is not an exploitable bug.
Is that ethical hacking or not?
Cause you're deceiving the company into paying you.
Um,
what do you think?
So for the,
from like a program perspective,
the way that I would view this is that,
well,
for one,
it would be hard to pay that out except for like a low or maybe a low end of
medium.
And the reason for that is that you shouldn't pay it out at all.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
so,
well,
here,
here's why I might consider paying it.
And the reason is that it's a security disconfiguration.
Right.
And so the reality is that like,
is something wrong?
Yes.
Is it exploitable right now?
No.
Would it be exploitable in certain edge cases?
Potentially.
Right.
Like maybe you could exploit it in an older browser or,
uh,
like certain browser.
I don't know.
Right.
Like there,
there might be certain edge cases where it's,
where it's possible.
And I think the fact that it's there and written and show,
like all it takes is one slip up for that to go wrong.
Um,
but it's not exploitable.
Right.
Like,
like you said.
And so I think that is a huge mitigating factor that like almost nullifies
your bounty essentially,
because what's the security impact?
Nothing,
but what's the security issue?
Something.
And so I think it's kind of towing the line between a bug and not a bug.
I could see like 50,
50,
whether or not the program wants to accept it or not.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would,
I think it's ethical.
You think it's ethical,
even though,
even though you know that there is no possible way for it to be exploited.
I think the ethics are the same for the program as it is for the reporter,
whether or not they want to accept it and pay it out.
Or like,
if the program says,
I'm not going to accept this,
that's kind of the same ethical decision in my mind as the reporter reporting it
again,
even though it's not exploitable.
because the program is accepting,
well,
the program is accepting something that's not valid.
And the research is submitting something that's not valid.
But the program in this scenario,
the program doesn't know that,
right?
The program doesn't know.
Okay.
That's a,
that's a big caveat.
If the,
if the program doesn't know that it's not exploitable,
well,
first of all,
that's a problem.
This shouldn't stop the triage,
right?
Like,
it's triage.
You should see this and be like,
I can't exploit this.
And it probably should never even make it to the team.
If the team either doesn't have triage or they decide to accept it anyways,
that,
uh,
if they don't mention it,
like,
I feel like somebody should mention it.
Right.
Here's another,
here's another fringe case,
right?
Let's say you have an injection of a URL of a JavaScript URL into an,
an a tag with the,
uh,
target blank attribute set.
Right.
And somebody clicks that link.
It won't trigger in the browser because,
uh,
you cannot trigger JavaScript URLs on,
on,
uh,
underscore blank target blank,
um,
a,
a HTML tags.
I couldn't get that out.
Um,
and so,
you know,
that's not exploitable,
but like you said,
they're one,
uh,
deleting one attribute away from an XSS,
but you know that that's not,
not,
you know,
exploitable.
So is it ethical for you to report that or not?
So I think that is a little more of a clear cut case in my mind than the headers,
because the headers are very explicitly like you're setting a header and your response.
This is configured incorrectly.
The fact that just like being able to put a URL in an element,
but that's not exploitable.
I don't,
well,
yeah,
I don't know.
I'm going back and forth.
It's tricky,
man.
It's not,
well,
I guess,
I guess in order to,
in order to devil's advocate,
my own point,
right?
I guess I would say that there's nothing really,
there's nothing unethical about seeing whether something meets the criteria that a company has for their threat model,
um,
for their organization.
Right.
And,
and I guess it definitely has to be,
uh,
I think the rub is where,
how you describe the issue in your report,
right?
Like,
are you saying,
Hey,
you know,
click this link and you'll get an XSS.
And then you actually don't.
And you're like,
Oh,
some browser restriction,
blah,
should work in other browsers,
blah.
Or are you saying like,
Hey,
this isn't exploitable in any active browsers,
but I thought you might want to know,
cause you guys are very close to making a bad mistake.
Right.
And I think transparency is like the biggest thing here from both sides.
Yeah.
And so like,
as a researcher,
if this is something you're going to report,
be ready for the program to not accept it.
Like just,
you know,
test the waters though.
I think that like what,
what you suggested there is a good idea,
submit it,
see how they react,
see if this is something they care about.
Some,
some security teams care about misconfigurations like this a lot and they'll
accept it and they'll pay it.
Yeah.
And like a security issue is a security issue,
even if it's not fully exploitable.
I respect that.
You know,
but I think it's really up to each program to decide how they want to
handle that.
And if it's something they want to say,
sorry,
this isn't informative.
And then they fix it.
I also don't really have a problem with that because in most,
like if,
in most cases,
if you report something to a bug bounty program,
I could understand you getting frustrated if they,
they closed it and then they fixed it anyways,
but this is not exploitable.
And so it's really more just,
you're letting them know that this is a thing.
And if they want to like toss you some points or like,
you know,
a small bonus bounty or swag or something like that,
I think that's more than reasonable depending on,
again,
depending on the program,
but there's not really a great clear cut case for it.
I'm a little bit,
it's a little bit interesting to hear you talk about maybe potentially,
maybe paying bounties for things that are not fully exploitable.
I might have to give your program a try sometime.
Oh,
now I'm going to have to go and look at all the security
just configuration.
No,
you're good,
man.
Yeah.
Jubabs,
thanks for the question,
man.
I think that that's a,
that's a good one.
And the only other scenario that kind of pops into my head about
whether or not like it's ethical for,
for us to participate in a bug bounty program in all scenarios is this case of
lying about severity as well.
And,
and,
you know,
we have a friend,
I think,
you know,
what friend I'm talking about that,
that,
that always like just goes very,
and I'm not sure,
I'm not saying he's lying about the,
I'm sorry,
they're lying about the,
the severity of the bug.
Um,
but like,
it's definitely strongly worded.
Right.
And I have a little bit of an ethical thing about this because at the end of
the day,
like the people on,
on the triagers on,
on the security teams and stuff like that,
they're seeing a lot of reports,
you know,
um,
oftentimes they're not,
they're not the ones that are also doing the offensive hacking.
Right.
So they're not as,
you know,
intimately familiar with the details of,
um,
the boundaries of all of these bugs.
And so,
you know,
pulling a fast one on these guys to gain a buck or two is I think,
uh,
inethical.
So on,
in,
yeah,
I'll agree with you on that.
Yeah.
Unethical.
I think,
um,
I think everybody,
especially people who hack a lot and like full time and that kind of stuff,
this is a really tricky and easy hole to fall into because when you're submitting
stuff,
like you don't really want to,
you know,
toot your own horn too much,
but at the same time,
you also want to like,
you know,
critical information being leaked,
like,
you know,
you want to sell it.
I mean,
you gotta,
you want to get your report attention,
you know?
Exactly.
So like,
I think there's a line between like,
you want it to,
to be like,
this is like to demonstrate that there's impact here.
So the team doesn't under play it,
but also,
you know,
you don't really want to be like,
I don't,
I don't like lying to programs.
I don't think like,
I think if you have to lie and you're like being dishonest,
I think that's kind of where I draw my personal ethical boundary of like,
where's this ethical hacking?
And like,
where's this not ethical hacking?
Um,
and the reality is that if the like triage is in the programs and everybody is doing their job properly and they read through the report properly,
they should see through that still and they should pay it appropriately.
And if you as a hacker have a problem with that,
that's not really the program.
Well,
I,
I also think here's another,
here's another scenario that,
that I've kind of felt a little ethical quandary on before is like,
I don't know,
man,
like clearly this is not an ethical problem,
but I feel really bad about sometimes,
not all the time,
but sometimes I feel bad about reporting bugs that will just clearly never,
ever,
ever be exploited.
Like,
like,
and they are bugs and they're valid,
you know,
let's say access control bypasses or whatever,
but like,
I cannot even fathom a world in which some attacker would be like,
I'm going to like unsubscribe you from these email notifications,
you know,
like,
I'm not going to try to get too doomer about this because I mean,
you can really extend this to like every small program and be like,
who's even using this thing?
Oh,
no,
that's true.
But,
you know,
but I think like,
a bug's a bug,
you know,
bug bounty is kind of a game.
Yeah.
We've talked about this.
There's a lot of meta aspect to how you report stuff and all that kind of
stuff.
So I don't know.
It's a,
it's a very tricky,
it is.
It's a very tricky line to,
to figure out where that is and how you should be reporting stuff and what's
ethical and what's not ethical and all that kind of stuff.
So yeah,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Okay.
So scope,
right.
That's the other thing that you,
Bob mentioned in their comment.
Is it ethical to go out of scope to attack?
An in scope asset.
Okay.
So actually I'll,
I'll take first take on that one while you think,
um,
I'm going to say no.
And the reason for that is that it's technically illegal.
Um,
and,
and so even though you're,
you have goodwill and you have good intent and you know,
you're not going to,
you know,
weaponize these vulnerabilities to attack anyone else.
Uh,
the fact that you are hacking a system that you are not authorized to hack,
that crosses an ethical boundary that,
that it's kind of like,
to me,
it's kind of like trespassing,
right?
Like you,
you,
you're not going to,
you know,
break anybody's house or like,
cut down somebody's trees or something.
But if you're walking through their property for,
uh,
you know,
a period of time,
that's,
it's not hurting anybody,
so to speak,
but it is technically illegal.
Um,
and that's why I would say going out of scope,
uh,
is not,
is not a good,
not a good practice.
And,
and I think there are some scenarios where I will say,
I've seen programs do this sometimes where they'll say,
Hey,
um,
star.site.com is,
uh,
is in scope,
but not eligible for boundaries.
Um,
and then,
but you know,
www.site.com is eligible for boundaries.
And in those scenarios,
since it's technically in scope,
you can hack on that all you want and then try to use that to affect www.
I think that's a really good configuration.
Yeah.
Um,
this is one of those really tricky cases.
And again,
this is going to be program by program.
Um,
it's just,
you know,
I have to say,
I'm pretty proud of that trespassing analogy too.
You know,
like,
that's a great analogy.
That's pretty good,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Like,
I think that's a great analogy.
man,
it's so hard because like,
I think all programs should be paying for impact.
Right.
And yeah,
that means that going out of scope to provide impact on the main scope is still impact on the main scope.
However,
just like you said,
it's going out of scope.
And that by definition is like violating the program terms and like doing things that you shouldn't be doing.
And so,
you know,
it's again,
it's kind of one of those cases where if you submit something like this,
don't be surprised that the program's like,
hell no,
this is absolutely not.
We're not going to accept this like this,
you know,
and you shouldn't have done that.
And you're lucky we're not betting you.
Right.
Like,
I think that like the program has every right to be frustrated and mad.
If you do that,
on the other hand,
impact is impact.
And if you can show some really solid,
like if it's a critical,
I think as a security team,
I would have a hard time being mad if it was a third party because it's a critical.
Like if you can provide critical impact to my program,
even if it's a third party,
one of the things you have to realize as a security program is that the relationships that you have with your third parties and the way that you handle accounts and data and all that kind of stuff sharing with third parties is your responsibility as a security team.
It's not just like,
oh,
that's the third party now.
Like we're,
you know,
totally wiped clean of our liability here.
No,
like your,
you know,
data and whatever is still involved there.
So you should still own that to some extent.
But this,
I think goes back a little bit to like the whole zero day.
Like,
should you report a zero day to a program and that kind of stuff?
And where does the responsibility lie for bounty?
And should they pay for it?
And all that kind of stuff.
And like,
it's a very tricky scenario.
Like,
I think at the end of the day,
the security team is still probably going to reach out to that third party and they're going to get it fixed.
And they're going to figure out how to fix it from their side so that it's not creating that impact on the main program or on the main scope.
Yeah.
But as a hacker,
you are definitely crossing some lines there and you're opening yourself up to some risk by going out of scope and reporting something that's out of scope and explicitly,
you know,
kind of violating some,
some boundaries and some rules in order to get that critical.
Okay.
So yes,
I hear that.
And it actually makes me think of a better analogy for the trespassing.
Okay.
So this time I'll take my no trespassing sign down.
This time we're trespassing,
right?
But we're doing it back up.
We're doing it to save a cat.
Oh,
well,
say less.
I'm sorry.
Not a cat,
a dog.
No,
what's wrong with cats?
I just,
actually,
I told you that I'm no longer allergic to cats,
right?
Yes.
Apparently.
I am.
I'm free of my lifelong allergy to cats.
And I pet a cat for the first time in my life the other day.
And it was like crazy.
It was lit,
man.
Anyway,
so I'm going to put it back to a cat.
We're trespassing on the property,
but we're doing so to save a cat.
Right.
Okay.
How does that feel?
Right.
Like that feels,
that feels.
Okay.
Maybe even,
even more accurate would be we're trespassing on a property looking for a person's lost cat.
Right.
Because,
because at the end of the day,
when we're bug hunting,
we don't know that we're going to find a bug,
but if we do find a bug,
we are helping that,
that,
that program.
We are finding that person's cat.
Sure.
And so I'm going to use an America analogy here.
Okay.
So in America,
if you were to do this,
you also,
yes,
exactly.
That's exactly where I was going.
50,
50 chance,
right?
Like that homeowner has every right.
You're on their property.
You're on private property.
You're trespassing.
Like you didn't ask permission.
For all of you that don't live in America,
it's not actually a 50,
50 chance,
but there is definitely a non-zero chance that you'll be shot at.
I have been shot at multiple times in my life for being,
for trespassing.
Yes.
Okay.
That's crazy.
We need to talk about that off air.
Holy cow.
What?
Okay.
That's,
that's some,
that's some Virginia stuff right there.
That's some Virginia stuff right there for sure.
But yeah,
no,
I think like,
okay.
In the same way that like the homeowner or whatever has the right to defend
their property and like tell you to get,
get the hell out of there.
Same thing for the program,
right?
Like they have the right to say,
this is not in scope.
We're not going to accept this.
Get the hell off my property.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And you know,
as a researcher,
don't be surprised if that happens.
That's kind of the risk that you're accepting by submitting that stuff.
So yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think you can't play stupid in these,
in these situations as a researcher.
Like you definitely,
you definitely know what you're doing.
Like if you're going out of scope and you're writing up that report,
you know,
like there's a risk that they're going to say no,
or they're going to get mad about that.
And you know,
hopefully you have a good relationship with the program or hopefully it's a,
it's a program that is willing to look past that.
But you know,
there's always going to be the chance of mitigating factors or not accepting it
or marking it as NA or informative and still fixing it on the backend.
And you know,
those are things that might happen.
I will say as well that,
um,
there are some,
I guess,
caveats being made in computer fraud and abuse act laws,
um,
for good faith security research.
And so I haven't really gone down the rabbit hole lately of what that actually
looks like.
And especially for like people like us who have an established record as of
ethical hacking,
I'm not sure if going out of scope would technically be illegal.
Um,
and if it,
if it,
if it is,
then that ethical boundary is still there.
But if it's not,
then yeah,
that's not,
yeah.
I forget what the exact wording is.
It's either best intent or good faith security research or something like that.
I think in terms of legality,
uh,
now the reality,
let's get into the weeds a little bit.
They are,
they didn't actually change the CFA.
The justice department made a statement that said,
this is how you should prosecute the CFA.
So if you're adhering to,
you know,
best intent and good faith ethical hacking,
then that shouldn't be illegal according to the CFAA and it shouldn't be charged.
But that,
I think that's separate from bug bounty,
right?
Like in terms of ethics,
I don't know,
like you're,
everybody's ethics are different in terms of legality.
It's probably legal,
at least in the U S and in terms of validity for eligibility for a bounty.
Well,
um,
well,
what if it's against my ethics to do something illegal?
Well,
that's a personal choice.
Right.
Um,
cool.
Cool.
Well,
today we're kind of,
we're kind of just,
you know,
screwing around.
So I'm going to tell you the story about me getting shot at.
Cause it's pretty,
it's a pretty great story.
Okay.
So I grew up in Virginia and like a couple hundred yards.
Now it was probably like a mile actually.
Um,
behind my house,
there was this really awesome waterfall,
like 20 foot waterfall,
um,
massive waterfall built by slaves in the civil war.
And,
um,
and pretty cool.
And so it was had like,
you know,
it was flowing water,
very beautiful area,
but it was on somebody else's property.
And,
and so,
uh,
but it was very far from their house.
Right.
Like,
okay.
You know,
it like you could barely see their house in the distance.
Right.
So I,
so on their property,
it is definitely,
it is definitely on their property.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so,
you know,
being the kid that I am,
I've snuck out there a couple of times and,
you know,
enjoyed the beautiful.
How old were you at this point?
Okay.
Hold on.
Like,
let's,
let's hold off on that one.
Um,
so we,
so,
you know,
when I was a kid,
I used to go out there often.
Right.
So,
but this time that I'm talking about,
that I got shot at,
I was,
I was a teenager.
Let's just say,
you know,
not a,
a young teenager.
And,
um,
I was going to go on a picnic with my girlfriend.
Uh,
and so my girlfriend and I were walking,
you know,
through the woods.
I had made like this little like basket and it was all cute and
everything.
And we're like,
you know,
walk into the waterfall.
It's going to be so fun.
And then,
um,
all of a sudden I just hear shots ringing out of over our head.
Holy shit.
And,
and I look across the lake and I see like very,
very far away.
I mean,
the person is like this small at this point,
but they're standing on their deck with a gun.
And we just like book it back the other way and move our picnic to the
middle of the woods.
That was on my property.
Holy God.
I was,
you still did the picnic.
Oh yeah,
we did the picnic.
We're not about to let a good,
you know,
ham sandwich go to waste.
No,
sir.
A little bullet doesn't stop my ham sandwich.
No,
no,
I still had,
still was hungry,
man.
Um,
so that's awesome.
Yeah.
This is a little bit of a little bit of an off,
off brand critical thinking episode,
but you know,
such as life.
What a wild,
a little childhood experience there.
Holy cow.
It's kind of crazy.
Um,
all right,
let's see if there's any of these,
any other,
um,
questions on here that looked good.
You could,
you could run them through real quick,
how to set up a mobile intercept proxy.
That kind of,
I feel like that kind of,
yeah.
Just talk them through that real quick while I figure out some other
stuff.
Yeah.
So typically what I do,
regardless of whether or not it's an emulator or a physical
device,
um,
if it's a physical device,
plug it in.
Um,
but either way you just want it,
to show up on ADB and have debugging enabled.
And then from there,
you just do ADB reverse TCP colon 80,
AD,
TCP colon 80,
AD.
And what that will do is it creates a tunnel between your host
and the device,
um,
on port 80,
80.
And so that means that any traffic that's going to port 80,
80 on the device will get tunneled to port 80,
80 on your host machine.
And that's seriously the easiest,
like most straightforward foolproof way that I've found to proxy.
You don't have to worry about network conditions.
You don't have to proxy to an IP address.
You literally proxy to one 27,
zero zero one port 80,
80.
It goes over ADB.
It tunnels and there's no connectivity concerns or anything like that.
It's,
it's great.
So,
so then you just go into the mobile app,
um,
or the,
the mobile devices,
uh,
wifi settings,
the wifi settings,
set up the,
the proxy to point at local host 80,
80.
Yeah.
Just edit your network proxy manual host,
one 27,
zero zero one port 80,
80.
And yeah,
it should work that easy.
You should be able to,
you know,
just navigate to like burp in your browser.
If you want to get the CA cert,
um,
all that stuff should just work.
So,
yeah.
And then,
and then the easiest way to download the CA cert,
like you said is just hit a local host 80,
80.
They'll see,
you'll see a little CA cert,
a button up at the top right hand corner on the burp.
Click that download the search.
Sometimes you have to rename it to dots.
Yeah.
Or CRT.
Either of those from dot D E R.
And then you just go into your security settings,
trusted,
uh,
trusted credentials,
CA certificates,
install one.
And,
uh,
you just select it from your SD card and it's good to go.
That's the easy part though,
because most applications are implementing cert pinning.
So for that,
you're going to need some,
some,
uh,
some Frida,
SSL pinning bypassing secret sauce,
which,
which we talked about,
I believe on,
what was that episode?
That was an early one.
I think,
uh,
I think it was like 12,
12,
14,
12 or 14.
I'm going to pull it up right now.
Uh,
yeah.
14,
man,
your boy remembers numbers,
man.
Yeah.
12 was LA life hacking.
Is it 12 was Jay had X.
Uh,
okay.
You got,
you got this better than I do.
LA life hacking was 17.
Oh,
okay.
Wow.
I'm way off.
Cool.
But yeah,
no,
it's,
it's that easy.
Um,
you know,
very straightforward.
And,
uh,
I think during the mobile episode,
we actually talked about the Frida unpinning.
I have a universal quote unquote,
universal,
um,
unpinning scripts that is linked there.
And that works like 98% of the time for me.
I can link that in the description as well.
Cool.
Put that down.
Eagle,
Eagle meme.
And then,
uh,
cert pinning script.
Okay.
So,
um,
next topic that I,
so I kind of scrolled through these,
not gonna lie,
dude,
there wasn't a lot of great questions.
So come on critical thinking listeners,
give us something deep.
Like there,
there,
there's a bunch of people saying critically.
God,
could you just think like critical?
Okay.
Um,
uh,
so one of the ones that kept on popping up was how do you,
how do you approach a new target?
What's the first stuff you look at?
What's your process and what kind of steps do you do before you start hacking?
Um,
and I wish that we could give you a recipe,
but there's not really a recipe.
So,
um,
it really depends on the target.
Uh,
for me,
a lot of the time I try to figure out what the app is and how to use it like a human.
Um,
and so for me,
that often means logging into the application,
navigating around,
reading documentation,
um,
kind of keeping a general eye on the architecture of the application,
uh,
trying to understand whether it's like a single page app,
or whether,
you know,
you've got,
they're using a front end framework like react or view,
what their backend looks like.
Are there a bunch of different APIs or their microservices,
their graph QL,
that sort of thing.
Um,
I also look at off a decent bit.
So,
um,
uh,
at OAuth,
at the two factor authentication flow,
um,
any sort of alternative authentication paths,
like,
uh,
like one time password being sent to your email,
you know,
and you just click,
kind of click that link and it allows you in,
like Slack does.
Um,
those sorts of things are,
are,
um,
are pretty,
pretty,
pretty pivotal to my method methodology,
but it,
it very much varies,
uh,
with every single target.
Yeah,
for me.
So I think there's a couple of like core steps that I like to follow.
And it generally depends on like where I'm at within the process of looking at that target.
So when I'm starting out,
like from the very beginning,
a lot of it is like what you said,
it's figuring out what is this app?
What is it supposed to do?
Where,
where are sort of like the,
natural boundaries in terms of,
uh,
what functionality should be,
where are their access controls,
kind of identifying those nose,
like,
uh,
like Archangel was speaking about in the last episode.
Um,
and then from there,
if they have a mobile app,
um,
a lot of times I'll be looking at that and just see what activities do they have exposed?
What are the intent filters?
What,
what kind of functionality exists from like an external attack surface perspective on this,
on this app?
Uh,
is there any like weird JavaScript interfaces,
any web views,
any content providers,
any of that kind of stuff?
Um,
and I'll usually do a bit of a deep dive on the mobile app and just like see if there's any funky stuff that I should be poking at and trying to exploit.
If I don't really find anything there,
um,
one of the things I do like to do is look for API endpoints within the mobile app and just see,
is it different from the,
if there's like a web app,
assuming that is it different from that?
What is the auth structure look like?
How do you log in through the mobile app?
All that kind of stuff.
Um,
and then if I'm kind of hitting like a wall,
I'd like to split and sort of do recon or do like more breadth searching.
What other apps?
Trying to find new,
yeah.
Yeah.
Like what services exist,
subdomains,
things that are in scope that I haven't looked at that I might not know about.
Um,
are there any weird URLs or things that are provided in API responses from the mobile app or from the web app that I haven't looked at?
those are the types of things that I want to take,
you know,
a little bit of a closer look at and see if there's some bugs that I haven't found.
Or that I,
you know,
might be easy wins.
Um,
and then I kind of just repeat that,
like,
you know,
look for something,
find something,
figure out what the functionality is.
Dig.
If you run out of things to dig at,
try and move laterally and find some other,
you know,
or horizontally or whatever,
and try and find new things to look at and,
you know,
rinse and repeat.
Kind of grasping for straws right now,
man,
with this application that we're hacking.
Cause it's like,
the scope is so small and I've,
and I've exhausted all of it.
You know,
all of the attack vectors that I can think of over the past week.
Um,
you know,
I've tried them.
Uh,
and,
and so I'm really kind of going back over reiterating.
Um,
I'm reaching,
reaching for some really crazy bugs in like tangentially related third party
libraries that could result in vulnerabilities.
Um,
yeah.
So it's,
it's definitely,
that's definitely a part of the grind is learning how to push through those
scenarios when you're like,
uh,
I'm out of attack vectors,
but yeah,
oftentimes it's a really tricky.
Good stuff pops up.
I mean,
for me,
like,
especially for this event,
like the way that they have the scope structured has made it very difficult
for me to like,
want to submit everything I get.
You know what I mean?
Like I'll,
I'll find something and be like,
Oh,
that's kind of interesting,
but I don't even want to like dig into it because it'll be on like a domain
that's either explicitly listed as ineligible for bounty or it's not in scope.
Like the way that they have this scope structure,
you know,
I don't know if you're looking at it,
but it's very particular.
Yeah.
And so that has really limited the hacking that I've chosen to do for this event.
And I think I'm kind of holding myself back here a little bit because of that.
We should compare notes on that after this,
because I think there are some ways around a lot of that because of what you kind of mentioned
before about like having impact to the main domain and,
and,
and PayPal is really,
is really good about that.
If you can show impact,
you know,
um,
to,
to the primary application,
to the primary target,
then I think you've got,
I think you've got some good,
some good bones there.
Okay.
Cool.
Yeah.
Let's compare notes over here.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
sweet.
Uh,
yeah.
What,
so this next one was what,
what kind of steps did you take before you start hacking?
I think,
I think the only other thing I want to do,
to add to this one was,
um,
like really,
we talk about this all the time,
but like,
I get so much out of reading documentation and it's going to be dry at first.
And,
you know,
you're going to sit there and you're going to be like,
why am I reading this?
Uh,
but re,
read the main apps documentation and read the developer portal documentation,
because that's going to give you so much insight into the application.
And actually I missed multiple,
very critical bugs at the slide hacking event.
because I didn't read literally every single page of the,
of the developer,
uh,
section.
Um,
and had I,
had I read it,
I would have absolutely found them.
Uh,
but I missed it.
So sucks,
man.
It sucks.
It happens.
Um,
all right.
So,
uh,
before we bounce,
I've got three little,
three little things,
three little cool things.
And then I guess we can also,
we were also going to go over the reports,
weren't we?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
so I'll make these quick.
Uh,
all right.
Number one,
uh,
two tweets from your boy,
rhino reader.
Uh,
I just wanted to shout these out.
Cause these are kind of surprising to me that,
that some of these,
that one of you introduced,
that was like,
as if it was a guest,
but it's just you.
You're like from,
from this awesome,
from the man,
unheard of hacker before.
The legend.
Me.
No.
Um,
uh,
you know,
so here's the thing,
man,
like,
and I'm sure you get this all the time as well,
but like,
I get tagged in like five to 10 Twitter posts a day.
And I get saying like,
Hey,
run a reader.
And then like spam a bunch of other popular book bounty hackers.
Um,
how do I explain this thing?
Right.
And I try to respond to them if I can.
Um,
and so last,
last,
uh,
I guess two weeks ago,
almost now,
somebody was like,
Hey,
I found an open redirect,
but it only allows Google and target.com,
not other websites.
What should I do?
How can I exploit this?
And so I commented on it cause I knew the answer.
And the answer is Google has a built in open redirect that,
uh,
they don't patch.
That is just a part of functionality for Google.
And that is google.com slash amp slash S and then your target domain.
If you go to that,
it will redirect.
For the amp page reloads.
Yep.
Um,
and so,
uh,
it's just funny.
Cause does that work on mobile?
I believe it does.
Yes.
Um,
cause normally amp pages,
like I,
that behavior is typically restricted to mobile.
So I'm curious if it behaves a little bit differently.
If,
if you have like a mobile user agent and stuff,
let's see if we can,
uh,
simulate that real quick.
Yeah.
For those who don't know amp pages are essentially,
um,
it does not work for mobile.
Okay.
Yeah.
There you go.
So it doesn't do that.
Yeah.
So mobile,
typically the way that this works is that there's these amp pages.
I forget what it,
what it like stands for,
but it's,
it's meant to be basically mobile friendly versions of pages.
You see it a lot with,
uh,
news websites,
especially like mobile pages.
Yeah.
So it's really meant to be like a,
a simplified mobile friendly version of whatever page you're looking at.
Again,
I see it a lot with,
um,
journalism and news websites,
like art news articles and stuff.
Uh,
but typically if you try and visit an amp URL on desktop,
it does what you said.
It redirects you.
So that's probably why that's happening is that it detects you're on mobile and
it goes,
Oh,
let me try and render an actual amp page.
And if you're on desktop,
it goes,
go back to the main page.
Wow.
Very interesting,
Joel.
Uh,
I didn't know that,
that,
that's helpful to know why that actually works.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
So that if you're looking for a chain for your open redirects,
that's the one,
it was really funny because like,
they like this guy tagged me in this post,
I commented on it.
And then like that comment got more retweets and likes than like my normal
Twitter posts.
So I was like,
wait a second,
what the hell is going on here?
Um,
that's a good one though.
That's a really,
that's a really clever attack scenario,
especially for like desktop clients.
Yeah.
Um,
the other thing was I was exploiting an XSS the other day,
tweeted about it.
So,
uh,
if you guys haven't seen that,
you can go check it out.
But,
um,
I just wanted to mention it on the pod as well,
cause it's a nice little tidbit.
Um,
I was getting sort of,
um,
uh,
stopped by the X content type options,
no sniff header when I was trying to change a CRLF into an XSS.
So,
you know,
you're,
you're adding the,
the break,
then you're adding the content body,
you're providing content length,
that sort of thing.
Um,
but,
uh,
for some reason I couldn't,
I,
in the scenario,
the content type header had to be blank,
uh,
or else it would,
it would break it.
Um,
and if you try to do,
if you do content type blank,
it's going to try to sniff it normally.
But,
uh,
in,
in the scenario they had the no sniff header.
So,
so,
uh,
I actually added another no sniff header with an invalid value.
And if you have two no sniff,
uh,
content type options,
headers,
uh,
in one of them with an invalid value,
one of them with a valid value,
Chrome just throws the whole thing.
out the window.
And I was going to say like potentially for the,
even just for the content type,
providing two values of it.
One should,
I mean,
that leads to some kind of unanticipated behavior with how it's going to behave.
So,
yeah,
it definitely does.
And,
uh,
the reason we couldn't overwrite the content type was because the,
the,
uh,
CR left was in the path and you couldn't put a slash in it.
So you can't do HT,
you know,
text slash HTML,
right?
So we couldn't override the content type.
To,
to be a text,
uh,
an HTML content type.
We tried everything we could think of for that.
You have to have a slash.
So we said,
all right,
what about a blink content type?
And then HTML sniffing.
And that's how we got,
how we popped it.
But I was just really surprised to see the X content type options,
uh,
header.
If you provide two of them,
it's just like,
you know what,
actually we just give up.
We don't know what to do.
And then it just,
I'm also surprised that that's from a client side.
Like,
you'd think that would be more of just like a server side control that would,
you know,
do that if it didn't detect something or,
yeah,
well it's the browser is,
you know,
the header is the response header is for the browsers.
Uh,
you know,
it tells the browsers whether to sniff or not to sniff.
Um,
and so,
uh,
Chrome just said,
Oh,
so this is in a response header from an,
it's in a response header.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
I thought you meant in like an outbound request that you were changing the
request.
Uh,
we're injecting another X content type options header,
uh,
in the response and trying to trigger the XSS.
And,
uh,
in the browser says,
all right,
I'll sniff that.
If you give them,
uh,
I'll,
I'll sniff that.
I'll get that a sniff.
Um,
so I thought that was good enough.
We're getting,
we're getting silly.
And this is what happens when you stare at a screen for 12 hours a day.
Um,
okay.
Last little one.
This is actually a trick I used to,
to get an ATO,
uh,
at,
let's just say recently.
Um,
and,
uh,
and at recently,
at recently.
Shut up,
Joel.
Um,
uh,
so essentially this scenario was a scenario you,
we really often see,
which is,
uh,
you've got a,
a application that is using,
uh,
like Axios,
JS library on the,
on the front end to communicate with an API and they're authorizing,
they're authenticating into that API by an authorization bearer header.
And that header is just sort of stored in the JavaScript state and not stored in local storage or in a cookie.
Right?
So if you get an XSS,
normally you're going to,
you're going to try to pull your session token out of,
um,
uh,
local storage or out of a cookie.
Um,
right.
But in this scenario,
you know,
you can't cause it's not stored there.
So your option is you can go through the OAuth flow,
which in this scenario had a bunch of like crazy intricacies with crypto stuff,
uh,
to it.
Like you had to generate like a certain length nonce or whatever.
And then it had to get passed.
It was kind of a pain in the butt.
Um,
so what I actually did was I created an iframe,
uh,
to the same,
to same origin page.
Um,
and then that iframe,
when it loaded up,
it was going to try to reach out to the API to load data.
And I just reached into that iframe and overwrote the,
uh,
fetch,
function,
the window dot fetch.
And I,
I just put my own function in there.
I shimmed it is what it's called.
Uh,
essentially said,
okay,
anytime they call fetch,
call my function and then,
and then call fetch.
And if that function call has the authorization bearer header in it,
then exfil it to the attacker server.
So it's not a crazy hack,
but it is something to know that,
that is useful.
Um,
if you are trying to,
you know,
if you have XSS,
you have the opportunity to overwrite functions like,
like fetch,
um,
or other properties,
within the,
uh,
within the window,
um,
not all properties can be overwritten,
but,
uh,
most of them can.
And you can use that to save yourself some time.
And,
and,
uh,
when proving an exploit or,
and sometimes in some cases,
like JavaScript sandboxes,
you can actually use these to escape the sandbox and,
uh,
and get arbitrary JS execution.
That's super interesting.
I'm,
I'm curious how it,
how it's stored in a place where it's index,
where it's not in local storage and not in cookies,
but would like,
shouldn't it always be accessible from JavaScript if it's being,
I'm sure it is.
Set.
I,
I'm sure,
you know,
I could hit like window dot like react state.
Cause somehow it's setting it in Axios.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
And it's from within their like,
you know,
minified hell that is,
whatever JavaScript library they were using in the front end.
Um,
and so I just didn't feel like freaking traversing the whole,
you know,
JavaScript.
It's just easier to set your own function to,
to find that.
Uh,
and it took literally like two minutes to write the exploit and,
uh,
pulled it out really easy rather than having to do like an Oauth,
you know,
hijack this like Oauth flow and like generate a cryptographically
accurate,
you know,
notes or whatever.
So I figured I'd mention it cause it's a cool little trick.
It's,
it's actually,
unfortunately like the coolest thing I've done this live hacking event
because all of the bugs have been mega boring.
They've been like,
you know,
well,
actually I won't say what kind of bugs they,
they,
but,
um,
uh,
you know,
they,
they have not been very interesting bugs.
So yeah,
congrats to the PayPal team.
You don't have a lot of,
you know,
crazy,
interesting bugs,
just boring ones.
Congrats for having boring bugs.
Yeah.
Cool.
Um,
is it,
do I,
should I talk about my,
the bug that I had?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Let's go ahead and go over some bugs.
That's always cool.
It's always a dub.
Yeah.
So I had,
um,
I had a really interesting bug a couple of weeks ago.
Um,
and I,
I had talked to you about this cause I think we're both on this program.
It's a private program,
so I won't say who it is,
but,
uh,
the mobile app was primarily in scope and I was looking at the mobile app and there was some interesting functionality,
in one of the API endpoint responses.
And there was like a JSON object that had a bunch of different configurations,
URLs and stuff in it.
And one of them was,
uh,
a dot HTML file,
which kind of caught my eye because like a lot of times in modern web app infrastructure,
you really don't see like raw dot HTML like that.
Um,
and it just seemed like a kind of a weird end point.
And I was like,
huh,
like,
I wonder what that is.
And so I like,
I went to it and it rendered like some very strange stuff.
And there was like this login functionality where you're supposed to like log in so it can get your account.
And then you can,
uh,
do,
you know,
app functionality to schedule something.
That's what I'll say.
Um,
and so I was like poking at it and I was like,
huh,
this is really weird.
But I wonder like if this is actually being used.
Cause every time I would try and exploit it,
like I would click log in and it would send me to a different page.
I was like,
huh,
this is like,
this is kind of weird.
Uh,
maybe,
you know,
maybe this is just like a dev environment or something.
So I go,
I log in and I,
it takes me to like the main page.
And I noticed like very,
very similar to the dot HTML that I was looking at embedded within the page.
I was like,
huh?
Okay.
So I look and it's an iframe.
Um,
and it's,
it's an iframe from a different URL,
but it's rendering essentially the same thing as that dot HTML.
And so as I kept digging,
uh,
I realized that it does post message communications to talk back and forth because it's embedded
within an iframe and it has to pass authentication from the main site into this iframe.
And so I was like,
huh,
I wonder how that works.
Like,
how is it like,
what's actually triggering that to,
to,
you know,
send over the off?
Like,
is it a certain event?
what are the restrictions on that?
Could I put my own frame in there?
Like whatever.
So I start digging and sure enough,
there's,
I mean,
the stars really aligned on this one because there's this functionality for different environments
within this iframe.
And essentially it has a URL parameter,
uh,
called override URL.
And it essentially it checks for,
you know,
it's supposed to be that if you,
if you set it to local,
then it like uses one 27,
zero zero,
right?
Sure.
But they had,
you know,
they essentially didn't check if it was,
you could,
you could put whatever you wanted in there.
Like if it was just like,
you know,
if it's not in the URL,
then it just defaults to whatever you've set it to.
And so I could just set it to my own iframe and then it would embed my iframe in the page.
And so then I could send a post message to the parent.
Is this inside a web view in the mobile app?
Or is this in,
in like on web?
No.
So that's the weird thing is like,
it started out from the mobile app and then it ended up just being a complete web bug.
Like I only found that URL and the fact that it was iframe and all that from the config endpoint within that mobile app.
And then all,
and then I realized,
oh,
this is like on the main site.
It's like a different URL,
but the functionality is all the same.
Interesting.
So yeah,
I could set this parameter to my own URL.
It would then set the iframe source to that URL,
put it in the page,
and then you could send post messages to the parent.
And there was all these different like commands and stuff.
So initially I just,
you know,
I sent the one that it sends,
sends me the auth token.
I was like,
okay,
that's pretty cool.
And then I kept poking and I was like,
oh,
there's actually like a lot more functionality in here.
And so you could do all sorts of things.
Like you could,
you could,
it's ridiculous.
There was actually one action called go to,
and it would just do window dot location equals whatever.
So you could just,
you know,
a second,
yeah,
basically a second XSS.
You could get geolocation through one of the other actions.
There was like a lot of really interesting functionality,
but it all just stemmed from this random,
you know,
URL that I was like,
huh,
I wonder what that is.
And then when I was trying to log in with it,
I realized that it was sending me back to the main page and it was,
you know,
doing very,
very similar functionality,
but from a different URL.
And the team actually accepted it,
which is,
which is amazing.
That is cool.
Technically,
I think it was probably would have been out of scope according to the
explicit scope that was written down,
but it's on the main website and it's account takeover.
It's used by the,
the,
the in scope asset as well.
So.
Right.
Yeah.
So that was a,
Oh,
and I'm looking right now and it seems that they actually added,
they added the,
the main site to the scope.
Oh,
did they really?
It wasn't dude.
Yeah.
So that's dope.
We need to go check that out.
Yeah.
That was a,
that was a really fun one.
Um,
I've,
I've actually been enjoying hacking on this program.
You know,
the one I'm talking about,
but,
uh,
yeah,
they have a,
they have a pretty cool scope and it's something I use personally.
So after the live hacking event in,
in,
in Japan.
So yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
I love post message bugs.
Post message bugs are so much fun.
I,
we,
we talk about them all the time on the pod,
but they're essentially APIs for your,
your,
you know,
browser tabs,
essentially.
Yeah.
Um,
and why would you not want to remotely interact with a browser tab?
yes,
exactly.
Very,
very cool stuff there.
Um,
yeah.
Alrighty.
My report for the day is,
uh,
also a private program.
So,
uh,
can't really talk about it,
but,
uh,
I can tell you the gist of it.
And,
uh,
I will say that this,
chain starts with a XSS,
uh,
and it came from none other than Mr.
Today is new himself.
Eric.
So thanks for that.
Thanks for the assist there,
Eric.
Um,
and I found this whole,
whole chain and I had an XSS that had already been reported that I used to
exploit the first time.
They were like dupe because,
uh,
you know,
you,
you already use the XSS and you can't use it in another ATO chain.
And I was like,
guys,
you're literally putting your users at so much risk right now by not using
this.
I guarantee you there's another,
uh,
you know,
another XSS on your attack surface right now.
They could be used to exploit this.
They didn't accept it.
There we go.
A couple,
couple,
couple weeks later,
we do,
uh,
we do another,
um,
we do another run of it and,
uh,
find an XSS.
Uh,
Eric,
Eric finds it in his automation,
passes it over to me and,
uh,
we,
we exploit the bug.
So here's how it works.
Um,
essentially what it is,
is it's taking advantage of,
uh,
sort of a session fixation,
but for the password reset.
Um,
and so what,
what you can do is you can use an XSS on start out anything.
Um,
and you can,
uh,
take a,
a specific session that you can generate and stick it in a cookie and set
that cookie to a very specific scope.
Okay.
To the specific path.
So,
um,
the way that cookies work in the browser,
if you put a cookie at,
uh,
a more specific path than another cookie,
even if the domain is wider,
that,
that cookie will be prioritized when it is sent to the server.
So,
um,
let's say you have two cookies with the name,
uh,
you know,
session,
right?
If,
if the path that you're on is slash login,
and one of the cookies is set to slash login and one of the cookies is
set to slash,
the slash login will be sent to first.
And oftentimes prioritized.
And you're saying,
even if the cookie that's scoped for slash login is set to the star.
Even,
even if it's like specific subdomain dot host.com,
it'll still override.
I believe so.
Yes.
Um,
okay.
And so,
uh,
the only,
you know,
I'm actually wondering now whether both of them have to be set to the star
scope,
right?
Or to like dot site.com or whether that's interesting.
I'll have to check that.
But I know for a fact that if both of them are set to dot site.com,
then the one with that,
with the more specific path will be set first,
uh,
or will be sent first.
And so in that sort of way,
we can,
uh,
get our cookie to be prioritized.
So then another trick that we can do is we password,
or we cookie bomb the password reset,
um,
the password reset flow,
or the,
uh,
the login flow,
excuse me.
And when they go to log in,
if you cookie bomb that specific path,
then the request will fail.
Okay.
And,
uh,
because the header size is inflated because of the,
all the cookies you sent from the other subdomain.
Um,
okay.
Then when the request fails,
it just gives you an invalid password,
uh,
response.
Um,
and so what they're,
what are they going to do?
They're going to reset their password.
Um,
so they go to the password reset flow.
They,
they start going through the flow and,
uh,
when they get to the end of the flow,
there's a screen where you can set a new,
a new password.
Uh,
uh,
this whole time they've been using our maliciously set password reset token.
Um,
okay.
And,
uh,
at that point we,
use that password reset,
uh,
session to go directly to that page.
And then we set the password before they can set the password.
Um,
and then we take over the account.
Uh,
and that is the,
that is the account takeover that uses a,
um,
a cookie prioritization trick,
uh,
cookie bombing and,
sort of a session fixation bug.
So how did the,
how did the program,
and triage react to it?
Cause that's kind of like,
did it,
did it automatically take them to the password reset flow if it failed,
uh,
when you cookie bombed it or like during login or?
No,
I,
they,
they accepted the attack scenario that if you could figure out a way to tell the
user that their password is wrong every single time they try to log in,
that the next logical step would be to reset their password.
Um,
okay.
So yeah,
so it's essentially a DOS that leads them to,
you know,
reset their password so they can log in.
Cause it's saying invalid password or whatever.
Exactly.
Cause,
cause the login request fails every time because of the,
the,
uh,
the cookie bomb.
And then,
uh,
the password reset flow,
they,
they go down that path and then we fixated the session for that.
So super cool.
That's a super dope bug.
Pretty fun bug,
right?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That's a,
that's a really interesting one.
I'm going to have to look for stuff like that.
I almost never look for like cookie bombing stuff cause it really,
it's still case by case,
but that's a really good instance of it.
Yeah.
Cookie stuff.
This is another thing that they sort of came to mind when you were talking
earlier about what kind of things you,
um,
you look for particularly when you,
uh,
you are starting assessing a program.
For me,
I always look at the cookies and I look at the authorization,
um,
headers and,
and any sort of cool codes that are being thrown around from an OAuth flow or
anything like that.
Um,
it's very important,
especially on those websites where you've got like 50 bajillion cookies that
are being sent and you don't know which one's the session token.
You don't know which one is like sort of your elevated session token.
You don't know which one like tells whether you're not,
you should remember the username,
you know,
there's just so many,
so many cookies out there and they all just kind of get conglomerated
together.
And so I will give another shout out to something I gave a brief shout out to
in the past on critical thinking.
Um,
and that is the burps we plug in called,
request minimizer.
Uh,
this has saved me so much time.
This is something I,
this is something that I actually do.
I wasn't gonna,
I wasn't sure if other people do this and I think,
yeah,
I think we've talked about this,
but I,
if I'm,
you know,
messing with a request and there's a ton of cookies like that,
one of the first things I will do is I'll go,
I'll open the request inspector on burp and I'll do this manually.
I'll just like open the cookies.
I'll select like 80% of them and I'll just delete it.
And then I'll just send the request.
And if it succeeds,
then I'll do it again.
Right.
Exactly.
And,
and if it fails after the first time,
then I know that the cookie that I need is in there.
And so that I delete all the other ones.
And then if it still fails,
delete the other ones.
Yeah.
Two cookies.
So yeah,
that's kind of what I do,
but there's a,
there's an extension for this.
You're saying.
Yeah.
There's an extension for this called request minimizer.
And essentially what it does is it just tries to remove everything he possibly can from the request and still get the same response.
And I use this plugin all the time.
Really valuable for analyzing what exactly is important in an HTTP request.
So I definitely recommend it.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I'm going to have to,
I'm going to have to grab this for my,
for my burp.
Very cool.
Awesome.
Write this down.
Dude,
I think,
I think that's it.
I think that's a wrap.
Yeah.
I think that's,
that's pretty much it.
A good little chat,
get back to live hacking and all that kind of stuff.
Try to get some sleep before your flight.
Is it a,
is it a direct for you from,
from Virginia?
for sure,
man.
I,
no,
it's a,
it's a one little one,
one hop up to DC and then a direct to Hanada.
So not too bad.
I think it's like 15 hours or 16 hours total.
Not,
not too bad.
Cool.
I'm excited,
man.
All right.
Do you land on the 13th or 14th?
Tokyo in 15 hours.
Okay.
15 hours.
Yeah.
I land today for you.
So.
Okay.
Sweet.
All right.
Well,
I'll see you tonight then,
I guess.
Wait,
wait,
no,
no.
I land tomorrow.
Because I lose,
I lose time going to Japan.
I'll see you tomorrow.
All right.
Peace.
Okay.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Peace out.